I'm run left buttcheek model and scotch  punch over the years I've had more than  my fair share of success I can't  remember the last time I ate out of a  dumpster and I owe it all to my fans now  here's a little taste of what you're  gonna be getting we flew in from Los  Angeles and we're going through LAX and  go through screening and this guy's just  losing his [ __ ] mind cuz I guess he  doesn't travel that much you're not used  to this equipment and he's just going  crazy you know you can have fun with  that you can do what I do I take two  viagra and demand a pat-down  what's that your past mr. wife no idea  [Music]  you're gonna need to Pat that down pat  it back up again  give it a couple twists see if it took  to anything you might want to go wash  your hands for yourself skies sliding it  to God not you get to get a little lever  especially with me what's that your  pants is why  [Music]